una mariupol irreconocible desde la
distancia mientras moscú continúa su
intenso bombardeo sobre la ciudad
meridional asediada apuntando a
edificios civiles en un vídeo grabado
por la cadena de televisión rusa se
muestra a los civiles corriendo para
refugiarse bajo los disparos los
intensos combates callejeros se suceden
por toda la ciudad algunos cientos de
miles de personas aún permanecen allí en
la ciudad que ha sido asediada desde
hace tres semanas
esa era mi casa había un hermoso jardín
al frente mira lo que ha quedado es un
pequeño apocalipsis
en los últimos días algunos ciudadanos
han logrado escapar los corredores
humanitarios ayudaron a 30.000
residentes a evacuar hacia zamorilla
pero su vida no ha estado exenta de
tragedia en este hospital infantil una
niña está gravemente herida
esta niña va a perder su pierna está muy
traumatizada y no ha podido comer ni
beber durante días tenemos que
alimentarla a través de un goteo
intravenoso tomo
en el pasillo del hospital un padre yo
era desesperado la muerte de su hija
de ministerio corría hacia mi hija gritó
dominican dominica
pero ella estaba tumbada inconsciente y
pequeña no pude protegerte
mientras continúan los bombardeos rusos
sobre la ciudad las autoridades
ucranianas insisten en que no se
rendirán el presidente volodymyr
selenski califica el ataque de moscú a
la ciudad como un terror que se
recordara durante siglos